aujourd'hui nous accueillons deux
superstars le mans mik
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vas bien salée
plus tante elle aurait telle est sa
chance avec vous s'il s'agit du grand
amour
tout le monde a sa chance et écoute ce
vélo c'est pas une blague pour moi mais
vu ton but ça m'étonne pas que tu
comprennes pas
c'est toi qui l'a écrite ça dit qu on la
termine en singles aux hommes armés ont
tué un hymne du second
et on est
sérieux quoi c'était super nié non
d'accord d'accord j'ai bien peur qu'elle
était infectée par un plaisir a dit ton
type de garçon et coupe ce qui compte
pour lui sa petite personne c'est couru
d'avancé
êtes vous pressé de partir c'est un rêve
qui se réalise regarde j'ai quelqu'un a
présenté alors tu es là aussi pour moi
tu es le boss plutôt go
haut-parleurs zoé et sans moi tu t'en
serai jamais rendu compte il y avait
vraiment un truc j'en suis sûr est-ce
que c'était le même s'il l'était alors
tu dois aller te battre pour lui
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
dans ce sens
[Musique]